hi there today we'll look at
inconsistency in conference peer review
revisiting the 2014 eurips experiment by
corina cortes and neil d lawrence which
were actually the chairs of the 2014
eurips conference so they are going to
have access to some data that
the rest of us sadly don't have access
to but also it allows them to make
pretty cool research on how conference
reviewing works and whether or not it
actually can determine the quality of a
paper or how much of it is just random
subjective reviewer decisions
now this paper particularly here
takes up the papers that were subject to
the 2014 eurips experiment and tracks
them over time
so it's gonna it looks at the papers
that were submitted how they perform in
the subsequent years meaning how many
citations that they accumulate both for
the accepted and for the rejected papers
and they find some pretty interesting
results right here so we'll dive into
this the paper is not too long and the
conclusions are fairly straightforward i
still think it's it's really cool that
people actually follow up on this work
so for those of you who don't know the
2014 new rips experiment
that is the wrong color the 2014 eurips
experiment was an experiment in
assessing how much of review of
conference review is
random essentially
so what you did was and i think they
have a little section about this here
yeah so
they selected about 10 of the
submissions these were 170 papers and
these would undergo review by two
separate committees so usu whereas
usually you have a paper that goes into
a review let's call that a committee
which is a bunch of reviewers and an
area chair and they make the decisions
of whether to accept or to reject and
yeah at the end you have a decision so
in this experiment you would take a
paper you would actually give it to two
different committees committee one and
committee two committee one would only
be selected from kind of one half of the
reviewer pool and committee two would
only be selected from the other half
these were random assignments and
to the two pools and also the papers who
participated were randomly selected
so each of these committees would reach
their own decision accept or reject and
of course the interesting part is how
many of those agree or how many of those
disagree with each other and by the way
the paper would be accepted finally if
the max so if either of the committees
would accept the paper
and if i recall correctly this year's
nurips conference actually repeats that
experiment from 2014 so we're going to
have another data point in hopefully
assessing how conference reviewing has
developed over the years whether it's
gotten better or actually worse
all right so that was the experiment in
2014 but by the way the authors here
have decided that the name changes is
retroactive i never know i never know
when talking about old neurips
conferences whether i'm supposed to say
it was nips 2014 or new rips
in any case in this in this paper we're
doing we're doing eurips
so what was the outcome of that
experiment and that's pretty interesting
namely here you can see this these are
still 2014 numbers committee one um and
committee two
split up so
it's not the same committee one of
course but committee one would always be
reviewers selected from kind of the
first half of the population committed
to from the second half
they did agree on most of the papers as
you can see here for 101 papers they
agreed to reject from 22 they agreed to
accept however for 43 of the papers
one committee would accept and the other
one would actually reject so for about
25 of the papers the two committees
would disagree 25 percent it's
you know it sounds it's a lot but it
doesn't sound like that much but if you
look at it in a different way where they
say right here if the conference
reviewing had been run with a different
committee only half of the papers
presented at the conference would have
been the same so this is looking at if
you for example always go with committee
one you would have these papers
but if you would always go with
committee two you would have these
papers therefore but the simple
selection of the committee uh determines
about half the papers at the conference
so if you're at the conference you walk
through the the big halls of posters or
you look at the proceedings uh you you
have to keep in mind that half of the
papers are there
only purely because of the random choice
of or not purely but they wouldn't be
there had the
reviewing committee been a different one
half the papers that's kind of crazy and
of course this sparked a lot of
discussion right here
so this is the outset this was the
results from that time and now we're
going into new analysis
so they do three different distinct
points of analysis the first one is they
do um the title is called reviewer
calibration so they try to figure out
what portion of a reviewer's assessment
of a paper is let's say objective and
what portion is subjective so
what portion of a score is simply due to
the reviewer's subjective feelings about
the paper that doesn't match with any
other reviewers
scores
so here you can see this
for example
what you can do is you can build a model
you can build a model you can say
y i j
that's the score that the jth reviewer
gives to the eye of paper
and you know being the conference chairs
these these authors here would have
prime access to
that data so what you observe is y now
you can say we assume this is a
combination of three things first of all
we assume that there is some sort of a
objective paper quality which is f i
this is the objective quality of the
paper this is actually what the
reviewers are trying to predict so when
the reviewer posts the number y into the
system they're trying their best
to actually assess fi
however
there is also this bj right here and
this is the bias that the jaith reviewer
has in calibration so not everyone not
everyone sees the one through ten or one
through nine scale that we have in the
same fashion and therefore
what's like a three to me might be a
five to u so
we have to correct somehow for this and
the inclusion of this b j factor is how
we account for that and then lastly you
have this e i j factor right here
and this is the subjective portion of
the score so this is independent of the
objective quality of the paper this is
sort of the subjective bonus or penalty
that reviewer jay gives to paper i and
our goal is going to be to figure out
how do these two numbers compare to each
other how much of the score is objective
versus subjective after we have
calibrated for reviewer
for general reviewer bias
for calibration bias let's say
keep in mind this is a model this is a
how we imagine the world all we observe
is this y thing right here what we can
do is of course we can put up a linear
system of all the scores right
and of all the scores because every
reviewer does give more than one score
in this conference and every paper gets
more than one reviewers scores so we can
put up a linear system but it turns out
this is over parameterized um because
you only have as many numbers as you
have these parameters right here so the
rest both parameters they don't you
don't have enough data points to assess
that
now as as much fun as over parameterized
models are in deep learning they're
actually not that good if you want to
estimate a linear system so what people
do they come up with regularizers and
bayesian approaches and yada yada yada
i'll skip all of this
to just give you the numbers so
the
model that these authors come up with
determines that the factors of the
linear systems are as follows this here
is the factor that goes with the fi this
one is the one that goes with the bj and
this one is the one that goes with the
eij
and you see you you you you pull out
this one and then you simply compare the
number on the left to the number on the
right you'll see they're almost exactly
the same and that means and they
formulate this here
in other words 50 percent of a typical
reviewer's score is coming from opinion
that is particular to that reviewer and
not shared with the other reviewers
this figure may seem large sorry about
that this figure may seem large they say
but in retrospect it's perhaps not
surprising
so this is pretty i guess this is pretty
surprising to me uh but it is not that
it is not that i didn't expect it and i
think anyone who's participated in
conference peer review would expect a
number that is in
approximately this range because we know
that the review process is pretty noisy
and very very often uh individual
reviewers just kind of give weird scores
that you don't understand and here's the
reason you don't understand because
it's the source of them are
subjective and
largely not shared by other reviewers
so having figured that out having
figured out that about 50
of the variation uh
is due to
just subjective feeling of a reviewer
about a paper now they
sort of try to validate their findings
and for that they run a simulation so
the simulation is a it's a simulated
conference
so
we assume that each paper was scored
according to the model we've given above
and we estimated the accept consistency
through averaging across
a hundred thousand samples so now
they're simulating the conference with
this experiment done and they ask
themselves
if this is really the correct model then
we should get back we should get back a
consistency of the 50 we found above
right so because
above the results of the experiments
were that there was about a 50
consistency
in acceptance
in the experiment and now they go and
they look at all the papers and all the
scores and they determine that there is
about a 50 subjectivity in scoring and
now they ask themselves
do these two numbers match and they run
a simulation where every reviewer has a
50 subjectivity and they ask themselves
if we do
if we simulate this splitting up into
two committees and then um every
committee agrees by themselves do we see
the numbers that we found in the
experiment and the answer is yes
actually so you can see these are
conferences for a bunch of for a bunch
of
different scenarios namely for different
number of reviewers as you can see here
these are reviewers per committee so
random means there is no reviewer per
committee committee decisions are just
random
and you can see that
as the
accept rate of the conference goes up
the accept precision of the committees
go up because they simply they they
would
more papers are accepted and therefore
more papers would be the same if you
were to change the committee
what we're interested in is of course
the one with three reviewers which is
the most common reviewer scenario uh in
these conferences and that's this curve
right here
so the way to read this is that for
example if the conference had an accept
rate of 50 percent right here
then
we would expect a reviewer consistency
or an accept precision of 0.75
of 75
which means that
uh if we were to switch the reviewers
for a particular or for all the papers
75 of the paper would still be the same
remember that in our experiment only 50
of the papers were still the same if we
switched committee
but the conference also didn't have a 50
accept rate so for that we actually need
to go to the accept rate of the
conference which was something like 23
right here and then if we look that up
we are at about a 60 percent accept
precision now this might still be away
from the 50 percent we found in the
experiment however the experiment had so
little data that
the um
if you calculate the bounds on the on
what the true accept position precision
was from that experiment you can
determine that it was between 38 and 64
and the exact number we got is 61 so
this is still within the bounce of what
we found in the experiment so pretty
interesting uh this actually means that
the model they put up is a close enough
approximation to reality such that it it
predicts the experiment's outcome
and this gives us a little bit of a this
gives us a little bit validation that
we're on a good track right here so we
can sort of confidently say that about
half
of a reviewer's decision on a particular
paper essentially comes down to
subjectivity is consistent with what we
found in the experiment and it'd be
interesting to see how this develops
this year when we repeat the experiment
so
lastly what they were trying to figure
out is
well
are these reviews even worth it so to
say do they actually predict how good a
paper is and you know how do you measure
how good a paper is of course by the
number of citations so here they define
the citation impact as the log of the
number of citations and yes there is a
debate about whether citations really
mean a paper is good or influential or a
blah blah blah but we don't for better
or worse we don't have a a different
measure right now than number of
citations and it's been seven years
which is like three generations in
machine learning so there is a long
enough
time
that these papers had to accumulate
citations
so
do let's let's just look at the accepted
papers do the scores that the reviewers
give to the papers predict in any way uh
whether or not the paper is going to be
cited more or less so do higher scores
indicate more citations and the answer
is no not at all so here is a plot the
correlation is
0.05
this is
ever so slightly statistically
significant but not not really uh so um
you can
like at least for this particular
conference right here there's no
correlation between reviewer scores and
between reviewer scores and impact of
the paper in the future
it becomes a little bit interesting uh
when
you ask specifically
so because here the question is you know
is the paper novel
is it correct uh is it well written and
so on um
these are not necessarily indicators of
significance right if you accept the
paper to a conference only a small part
of it is is it significant if you
actually ask reviewers do you think this
paper will have a potentially major
impact
or not you get a slightly higher
correlation but also not really which
means that reviewers are kind of bad at
estimating uh whether
any given paper will have a big impact
or not
though to be fair for most papers the
answers is probably no
by default
however
the interesting part is when you ask
them um
about their confidence in their rating
and it is if i understand correctly it
doesn't even matter which rating um
but
for up for the rating that you give at
these conferences you have to provide a
confidence score like you say okay i
think this paper is really good but i'm
not very confident and if you simply
correlate the confidence scores as you
can see here the average confidence over
all your sort of confidences of the
paper
with the impact then you do get a slight
correlation which is interesting right
so the the authors here argue that
it might be that
there might be something like
clarity in the paper so if a paper is
written very clearly then
you will also be able to understand it
better as a reviewer which makes your
confidence higher
but also
since the paper is more clear it means
that the rest of the world will have an
easier time understanding the paper and
therefore cited more often
so this is a is a good hypothesis but
it's quite interesting that um
that the
confidence in papers uh it seems to
predict the impact better than the
actual assessment of the impact that's
astounding it's not super astounding
that confidence by itself would um
predict it but
that it does does so more than uh if you
directly ask people
i wonder what else we can ask um like i
wonder what weird questions we can ask
that will then up correlating with the
do it with the future impact like do you
like the colors of the of the paper
do you like the pictures
um so these were for accepted papers
they also interestingly trace the fate
of the rejected papers
so
they say only 414 were presented at the
final conference
so they want to trace the rejected
papers and they go through a lot of work
to try to figure out where these papers
ended up so they search for papers with
similar titles and and authors or same
titles and authors and
of course this is not a perfect process
but it seems like they've been able to
trace a lot of these papers to their
final destination you can see a lot of
papers are
discarded or some are simply posted on
archive or somewhere else of course the
discarded papers you don't know if they
somehow morphed into other papers or
something like this
but it's still pretty interesting pretty
interesting to see though they say there
are various uh error resources in these
plots
lastly
yeah here is the fate of the rejected
papers now they don't say exactly what
blue and green means in this particular
thing
in other plots in the same papers they
differentiate for example between papers
that have
been accepted somewhere else ultimately
and papers that have not been or that
they have not been able to trace so this
might be blue and green
i'm i'm not sure i haven't been able to
maybe i'm just stupid at reading but as
you can see if you look at the rejected
papers so this is the calibrated quality
score for the rejected papers
and here you can see that there is in
fact a correlation which means that for
the rejected papers the assessment of
the reviewers really does correlate with
how the papers will end up doing
ultimately though i'm gonna guess
well if
if the citation count is in here i'm
gonna guess the discarded paper must not
be in here
yeah sorry
but the the conclusion is that for the
rejected papers reviewers can tell
whether they're
better or worse for the accepted papers
not so much and that's what they said at
the beginning the review process is
probably good at identifying bad papers
but bad at identifying good papers
and this is it's not too surprising
because bad papers you know you can find
uh
it's really easy to recognize a a very
poor paper
but it's it's harder to recognize really
how good a paper is
you know compared to other good papers
so that was the paper they give some
recommendations for example they say
well maybe we should we should assess
papers uh on
on on some
um
on different
on different criteria than we do now but
they do guard they do warn against
saying we should do away with with
subjectivity all together because you
know as annoying as the subjectivity is
they argue is it also guards against
sort of the the the collective dominance
so it guards against uh sort of
making consistent mistakes so if all the
like if if the entire conference for exa
if the entire conference makes
consistent mistakes in in some direction
then the subjectivity might counter that
a little bit i'm not sure if that's a
super good argument i am generally for
noisy processes over super duper rigid
ones um
it seems though that the conference
review right now is a bit too noisy
uh i'd rather do away
with
uh just having three reviewers and
not having this accept barrier this is
my personal opinion i would just do away
with the accept barrier altogether you
know you submit to a conference you get
a bunch of scores and then you have the
scores like why do we need to divide
papers up into
accepted and rejected or you know like
it seems better to just put papers out
there and let the future let the future
researchers assess them in retrospect
rather than having three random people
with highly subjective opinions assess
them
but yes
probably a bit of noise is good in a
process like this if you do a process
like this they also
say well maybe we should not push put
that much value at publishing at top
tier conferences now i don't know how
that's gonna work you know like whenever
whenever
and yeah i wish i wish as well that we
could like change the collective
um
the collective thinking about our field
uh i don't i don't see that as a super
easy task though in any case uh this was
the paper let me know your ideas uh let
me know how you think this year's
experiment is going to turn out like are
we going to find more uh subjectivity
are we going to find less
how much disagreement do you think we're
going to find this
is going to be interesting so yeah
thanks for listening and i'll see you
next time